Now to play audio, we have to go beyond UIKit and
think about another framework called AVFoundation.
Let me bring that out.
AV stands for Audio Visual.
And there is a library inside this framework,
that we will use to play this audio.
>> My mom always said, life was like a box of chocolate.
>> So what I have done here, is I've added links to the instructor notes
that will list out all the classes that are inside AV Foundation.
We are going to use one of them to play the audio you just heard.
Your job is to figure out which class we should use to play audio from a file.
So go ahead and read the documentation, and
then type in the name of the class that can help us play audio from a file.